and you'll obviously be aware of this
city can transport for london announcing
this morning
that the weighting of masks will remain
mandatory uh on the tube and on bus
networks
in london what do you make of that i i
suppose you must disagree with it
no i was on uh either your program or
sky uh just at the end of the last week
saying that
whilst we're going from this being a
legal requirement to guidelines we do
expect
individual carriers you know the
transport organizations
uh to make sure that they are um uh
uh putting in place with whatever's
appropriate for their network
but why would it be appropriate to wear
a mask on a bus in london but not
to wear a mask on a train leaving london
so sure so
if you think about it the the airlines
for example have already said without
any
bus as far as i saw um that you'll need
to carry on wearing masks on those i
said last week
it will be a condition of carriage for
uh various different transport
organizations of which tfl
which tends to tend to have crowded
commuter trains
may well i actually said this they may
well want to have it as a condition
of carriage so it's very much in line
with what we
expected even wanted to happen on the
other hand if you're on a long distance
train you're the only person in a
carriage
you know it's it's late in the evening
or something there's clearly no real
point in wearing a mask we don't want to
say that it's a it's you know you're
breaking the law by not wearing a mask
in a situation where there's absolutely
no advantage in wearing that mask so
this is very much what we expected
anticipated and said
uh shouldn't would happen so if you i
travel on an empty bus to come into sky
in the morning i should be able to get
on that bus without wearing a mask
so it depends on what that transport
organization says so if the
well in transport for london they're
saying i should wear that mask so should
i wear it or should i not wear that
carriage
if the conditions are carriage to get on
that bus are you must have a mask on
then of course you must wear a mask it's
pretty straightforward um but
you know there's no it's pretty
straightforward it's also fairly
inconsistent though isn't it minister
well we are moving away from everything
is set in law i know we got very used to
it the last year and a half to a
situation where we say
uh actually uh you now um take
um either responsibility personally or
in this case
you'll be told by the organization that
you are stepping into or stepping onto
in this case
uh but there may be other occasions uh
where people are asked to wear masks
because
they're being a confined area and and
that that's quite right where
that's the point of the fourth stage of
the unlock which takes place next monday
and it will mean that people
responsibility starts to
return to people and to organizations
which is which is absolutely right
because we are
going through that on unlock stage very
cautiously i i do want to kind of
reflect on
what we saw at the weekend at wembley
and the events of the past couple of
days and
the introspection that appears to be
going on within your party at the moment
about
whether or not actions words bad by some
of your colleagues may have contributed
to the racism that england's footballers
experienced i mean do you agree with
your colleague steve baker and when he
says you know much as we can't be
associated with calls to defund the
police
we urgently need to challenge our own
attitude to people taking the knee do
you agree with them
i think it's really simple i mean racism
is abhorrent we never want to see in
society
we want to make sure that it is you know
kicked out
recognized in in all of its uh forms and
you know i thought our england players
clearly did a brilliant job and i think
you know we should we should always
cheer them uh
and uh you know i i would i would take
issue with anybody who
who says that we shouldn't do everything
possible to
get rid of of of racism and and and
that's that's exactly what's happened i
i thought that the comments about
pretty bitter well aren't unusual
because or odd because you know pretty
patel has spoken very moving
movingly in the house of commons about
her own experience suffering
and from racism she also referred to
taking on the need
for politics she also referred to taking
the knee as gesture politics a view
which plenty of people in the public
took and shared
and now you've got steve baker
suggesting that you need to challenge
uh the attitude within the party uh to
taking the knee
again i'll ask the question do you agree
with steve baker that perhaps
you know calling it gesture politics
wasn't the right thing to do
well my views is very simple i just
think we should respect
p everybody and and in whatever form
they want to show that they are against
racism is fine with
with me and i think um actually it's a
shame because
this is detracted from a phenomenal uh
performance by
the the england team who really got
together and and did england
proud uh and that's where i prefer to to
to
to leave it i mean i think uh we should
work all of us together in society and
start by accepting that nobody wants to
see
racism and you know if you accept
everybody is coming
uh from um the right approach an
attitude
in this then we'll get a lot further as
a country and actually you know kicking
out racism
can we at least get you to agree that
perhaps we're past the point now where
politicians need to stop
telling footballers to stop commenting
on politics
well look everyone the great thing about
living in a democracy is
everybody is welcome to pitch in on this
i suppose a bit like everybody became a
armchair experts about
what gareth southgate should do with his
team over over the match
that i've got i think that's i'm sorry i
think the competition is slightly
isn't it i mean politicians making
making state sorry footballers making
statements
about food banks and racism slightly
different from armchair
you know managers commenting on the
england football on the internet
you're asking my attitude towards it
they're welcome to i mean we live in a
free society people should be able to
comment on whatever
they like and i you know actually i pay
tribute to um some of the uh campaigns
which have
raised awareness and and uh we live in a
world where
it doesn't matter if you're a footballer
a politician a member of the public
everybody has a right to comment on
politics thank goodness that's the world
we live in
what what would your advice then be to
your colleague andrew rossendel who did
say perhaps
in response to tyrone ming's comment
yesterday that he should be focusing on
football rather than politics
well as i said i think everybody can
comment on uh politics that's the whole
spirit of a democracy isn't it i think
it's the whole point of it but what i
would also say
um is uh you know we are absolutely
united
uh as a government and i hope as a
country as well uh
boosting out racism we we abhor it
uh in fact you know in as a as a cabinet
we're more
ethnically diverse i think than any uh
in history as far as i can see
um so you know i think we're more
representative for the country in that
regard and
you know so it's it's a good thing and i
hope we can uh move on
it rather united on on this issue
because uh
who wants to live in a racist country
not me indeed
neither i am but but i do want to
understand it is a country mile away
from your brief there was that meeting
with the tech giants
uh between the prime ministers and the
tech giants yesterday look instagram
still seems to view monkey emojis
you know telling people to go home as as
not racist
what concrete action is the government
going to be taking about this as regards
the social media companies
yeah i mean of course it's racist to
post or allow those sort of things to
stay online and we're introducing the
online harms bill
and that's going to have a maximum time
of 10 of
an organization's global turnover
so this is a huge uh potential
uh fine i know the prime minister had
the social media companies
in yesterday and it was very clear with
them they need to do they are very
bright companies they're
they're brilliant at uh producing
algorithms and tech and
and doing remarkable um things they need
to be monitoring their networks
a heck of a lot more clearly
to make sure that they're dealing with
this racist abuse which is to say the
online harms bill
will cost them dearly if they don't